[Musique]
à
j'ai commencé le baseball grâce à l'eau
perdre mon frère tout le monde et mes
frères sont famille japonaise au japon
c'est france dans des bols au brésil du
coup mon frère a commencé à jouer au
baseball y avait 6 ans moi j'avais fait
on je commençais à jouer avec lui
j'aime accroché direct
[Musique]
dans ce sport c'est que j'aime bien que
tu ne peux pas être bon tout seul vingt
neuf joueurs avec toi c'est façon
bureaux sont les sports collectifs
tu peux être bon tout seul mais si ton
équipe est elle pas avec toi derrière
toi tu peux rien faire et laisser sa
femme c'est m
[Musique]
mon objectif cette année c'est d'arriver
en finale avec montigny pour se
qualifier pour les prochains pour la
coupe d'europe et voilà avoir une bonne
saison et faire des bons trieurs
maintenant si on peut être que j'aime
vraiment et j'ai toujours depuis le
début je viens mais accueillis ici je me
trouve